betty hier 21 ans comparaît libre à son
procès il a donné aujourd'hui sa version
des faits qui se sont passés cette nuit
de mai 2016 le jeune homme passe la
journée au chevet de sa mère fragilisée
après avoir été frappé par son mari et
beau père de l'accusé et diouf demir la
victime donc arrive ce soir là au foyer
ivre et s'en prend à son beau fils une
dispute éclate dans la cuisine et des
kirs âgé d'à peine 18 ans à l'époque
s'empare d'un couteau et frappe son
beau-père à de multiples reprises je me
suis défendu et n'ai à aucun moment
souhaiter sa mort affirme le jeune homme
aujourd'hui un beau père violent envers
sa mère et l'accusé lui-même c'est un
contexte familial qui permet d'éclairer
la manière dont vivait le jeune homme
avant le drame mais il est en aucun cas
une conséquence des faits insiste son
avocat ce qu'il a fait ce soir là il l'a
fait dans un cadre précis pour se
défendre d'une agression et il n'ya pas
question de vivre vengeance par rapport
à ce qu'il a pu vivre par rapport à ce
que sa famille a pu vivre c'est pas du
tout comme ça qu'il faut voir les choses
c'est comme tout à chacun qui est
agressée et qui voit sa vie en danger
c'est la possibilité pour lui de se
défendre de cette de cette agression
mortelle
dès demain des témoins seront appelés à
la barre et permettront d'en savoir plus
sur le profil de l'accusé
le verdict est attendu vendredi